All right.
So there does seem to me to be a rebirth
of a defense of free speech starting
again on the left. Possibly. I
see a little southern happening.
I did Jonathan Haidt heterodox and
some of the other organizations you're
involved in in fire.
There is this group of people kind
of making a comeback on the left.
I'm not so sure it can hold,
I hope it can hold. Um,
but what do you make of how this sort
of bounces back where sometimes free
speech is something that
the left holds more deer.
Sometimes it's finding the right holes,
more deer and it kind of
switches as the decades go by
perspective. And I'm not far be it
for me to pull out the age card,
but I think a sign a few more
decades than you have. And,
and that it's been a constant,
that was very well summed up by Nav
handoff from you would have loved,
I don't know if you've ever
crossed paths with him. Um,
but he was a great free speech,
stalwart and he wrote a book whose title
really says it all freedom of speech
for me.
But not for the how the left and right.
Relentlessly sensory each other.
And he wrote that decades ago.
But it's always been true that most people
being human believe in free speech in
general.
But yeah,
those ideas that they hate or despise
or think are dangerous should be the
exception. Let's go back to
Skokie. Where ACL, you members,
even 15% of these die hard
stalwart ACL you members.
I'm not surprised that the one exception
they want to make is for speech.
That's Dan and grading,
civil liberties and human rights.
But I had a friend who was the executive
director of the National Coalition
Against Censorship and she put
it so well, she said, Nadine,
everyone has his or her Skokie.
So at particular times,
I can tell you for every year I can tell
you this was the one exception or maybe
more than one exception that
liberals wanted to make.
And this is the one that can
serve as wanting to make.
And I would say in general,
you know, like, um, uh,
let's amend the constitution so that
it is a crime to burn the American flag
that has been supported by many,
if not most conservatives and by
a lot of liberals as well. Uh,
that and there's not been,
I think that is the single most hated
expression in my lifetime because no other
expression has led to a constitutional
amendment coming within a hair's breadth
of being ratified more than two
thirds of the Senate. I'm sorry,
of the House approved.
It came within one vote short of two
thirds of the Senate and more than three
fourths of the states.
So all of it.
That's not my long. When was that?
Maybe that was mid nineties. Yeah,
something around there. Wow. That's
incredible actually if you think about it.
Yeah. Where, where do you think Trump
kind of fits into the general discussion?
Cause I see,
look,
it seems to me that there is obviously
some sort of authoritarian bent to him.
That being said, we're
not being, people are,
as far as I know people are being jailed
because of free speech at the moment.
Do you think our institutions let, let's
say that his worst critics, he's, uh,
we're write about whatever
they think about him.
Do you think our institutions at this
point are strong enough to ward off that
kind of threat? And we don't even
have to make about Trump specifically,
but if there was truly like a
real authoritarian in office,
do you think that the,
the way our balance of powers in
our separation of powers works?
And again, I would have to say,
you know, Trump has certainly, um,
done a lot of saber rattling on
free speech issues and you know,
said that flag burners should be deported.
But let us not forget that Barack
Obama was responsible for, uh,
the most stringent enforcement of
the espionage act and you know,
press pressing criminal charges against
more whistleblowers than all pre or
prior administrations they
added together. So, uh, again,
a pox on both your houses.
So far the courts have
been a wonderful bull work.
The flag burning example is,
is a really good one.
It was a a two supreme court decisions
joined by both conservatives and liberals
on the court that struck down under the
first amendment laws that criminalized
desecrating the American flag while the
Supreme Court doesn't have quite the
last word, a constitutional
amendment could overturn it.
But I have great confidence that this
court would continue to uphold what has
been called the bedrock
principle of freedom of speech.
And that is viewpoint neutrality.
I summarized it earlier that the mere
fact that the viewpoint is hated,
whether it be flag burning or
whether it be racist speech,
that is never a justification
for censorship. Again,
they unanimously endorsed that
last summer in a hate speech case.
Yeah. It looks slightly shift
for a second. So when you
were the head of the Acl,
you,
what are the political pressures that
you're under that maybe the average person
wouldn't know from the,
from the headlines, like
involvement with Po, you know,
politicians with lobbyists,
et Cetera, et cetera.
So at the ACL you was at his,
and I was personally involved in, in
lobbying and testifying. I still do,
uh, testify before
Congress occasionally. Uh,
and I would say to me it was
a very privileged position
because we did not have
to be directly concerned about
partisan political pressures.
We could simply make alliances and
work with anybody that we thought could
support an issue that,
uh, advanced our cause,
even if we disagreed with on
other issues. And I remember, uh,
to me it was a great source of pleasure.
I remember on one piece of legislation
testifying before the Senate Judiciary
Committee,
and the chair was Orrin Hatch and the
ranking a minor minority member was Ted
Kennedy and they were both supporting
the same pro civil liberties position.
And I was testifying together with the
head of the National Association of
evangelicalism and the
head of the Mormon church.
And despite all of the differences
on so many other issues,
the fact that we could make common concern
that was on principles of religious
liberty and freedom of
thought and freedom of belief,
that's what I feel is
deteriorating a little bit. Uh,
so last year I testified a couple of
times on campus free speech issues and the
bipartisanship had really worn down even
though the theme was freedom of speech
on campus.
And even though the chair of the committee
who was Lamar Alexander Republican
and Patty Murray,
the ranking member Democrat,
they were both really solid
and great on the issue.
But the other members of the committee
just used it as opportunities to trot out
their own ideas of which free speech,
uh,
was bad and should be suppressed.
So some of the Republicans were saying
taking a knee by athletes should be
punished.
And some of the Democrats were really
saying Trump is violating free speech and
there's too much political grandstanding.
Right.
And that's why for as
critical as I am for the left,
I don't want free speech to become,
I don't want it to be a political
issue in the first place.
I don't want it to be that the right,
which at the moment I see more
tolerance related to diversity of ideas.
I don't want that to be the home. I
want there to be a balance. Otherwise,
we're just going to end up in that,
maybe be a little bit skeptical,
but I think that people tend to be result
oriented and that, uh, on the right,
there may be much more support for freedom
of speech on campus because they see
that it's views on the right that are
being squelched. Now, in fairness,
I'll give you a counter example.
Many years ago during this first surge
of political correctness on campus,
Mitch Mcconnell, um, well let me,
let me, let me put it backwards.
Um, it was Henry Hyde, I'm sorry,
a conservative Catholic from Illinois who
was completely on the opposite side of
the Aclu on abortion and gay rights.
Um,
he really was so strong on campus free
speech that he sponsored a bill that
would have required all
private universities to
respect the same free speech
rights that public universities
are required to observe
under the constitution.
Many people don't know this, but the
constitution only applies to government,
including state universities,
but not private university.
How did you guys feel about, well, we
totally supported the ledges. Again,
that would be a difference. We train
libertarians and civil libertarian,
my libertarian friends would say, you
know, keep the government out of it.
Let the private institutions decide.
And there were exemptions
for religious institutions.
But basically I think that's where
I would fall on this. So sell me,
sell me your way. It's a very
interesting debate and I can understand,
but the person,
and you know,
I've had this discussion with my dear
friends at the Cato Institute for many,
many years now.
What's the difference between a classical
liberal or libertarian and civil
libertarian?
Uh,
I think that we are less opposed to
government regulation when it is in the
service of regulating very
powerful private sector
actors that for all practical
purposes,
the way we were talking
about civil society earlier
can exercise coercive power
that stifles people's
liberty. So, so what if you,
uh, you know, a few,
if we did not have the 1964 civil rights
act than even the most powerful large
landlord, employer, corporation,
private university or etc,
would be able to discriminate on the
basis of race or gender under federal law,
they still can on the basis
of sexual orientation.
I would view that as something that could
and should be remedied through passing
a statute, making that illegal. Hmm.
So usually report into, well I think,
well first of all, I agree with you,
your basic premise here,
just at the idea level,
it's a great place for a
rich conversation. Yeah.
The idea that the government would be
coming in and telling private schools,
even though I understand
what you're saying,
that they would have to adhere
to these codes even if I,
it being the first amendment.
Yeah.
I don't necessarily think of private
schools should have to do that.
I just think that ultimately
the market would just,
you'd either decide you want to go there
or don't want to go there. This one,
this one's definitely a tough one.
It's an interesting one and I definitely
can see the other side and I certainly
would insist on some exemptions.
Uh,
certainly for religious schools. I think
military schools were also exempted.
But then I want to give
you another example of a
Republican that I worked with,
Mitch Mcconnell,
uh,
worked very closely with
the Aclu in opposing,
and many people are going to
be surprised to hear this. Um,
the McCain fine gold law,
a campaign,
so-called campaign finance, the ACL, Ooh,
very,
you know,
we are the ones who argued Buckley versus
Valeo and arguing that the ability to
spend money in order to promote a
message is protected free speech.
And it should be protected even when
speech is engaged in by people who are
organized into a group and including
if they're organized in the form of a
corporation or a union or
not for profit corporation.
So some liberals are really distressed
by that position and I think it's
absolutely the correct one anyway.
Um, what, what do you say to those?
Those liberals are the lefties who do
get more upset about that in general,
that you're just going
to allow corporations to
endlessly pour money in the
system and manipulate the system.
And that's it.
Well, the track again, what
is the lesser of two evils?
Would I rather have the government
telling corporations such as the Acl,
you and planned parenthood
and the Sierra Club,
you name your favorite left wing,
so called cause.
And it is organized in corporate form
and the HCLU under that law was it would
have been a crime to go on the airwaves
and by name call on people who are
running for federal office and say,
you know, repeal the Patriot Act. Uh,
because arguing for issues over the
broadcast airwaves was a crime under that
water and spending your own money to
advance your own issue oriented message.
So I think people are shocked when they
hear what the law actually did and are
persuaded that in at least some
applications that went too far. Well,
McConnell became such a supporter of free
speech as a result of working on this
issue that he actually changed his
position on the flag burning amendment.
He had been a big proponent of it and
as having seen how important freedom of
speech was,
including for what to liberals is a
very controversial form of speech,
namely spending money in the political
process. Um, he said, well, you know,
I've got to stick to principles here and,
um,
we should not amend the constitution to
outlaw another controversial expression.
So I thought that was a really wonderful
idea of not just being result oriented
toward your own ideological concerns,
but seeing their overarching
principle and following it.
It's almost like if you
actually have the debate,
you might change people's mind and be
surprised to your, your ally suddenly,
or is there any country that
is protecting these rights? Uh,
better than we are known for
as screwy as our system may be.
No.
Uh,
well let me make eye on sexual expression
that United States is a much more
repressive than a European, uh,
some many European countries.
But like in what regard? You mean
with what can be seen in magazines?
There's living, yeah, so we still have
a, I mean, not only sexual expression,
but four letter words.
I mean,
thank goodness we're not rod casting
because I still get bleeped even when I
tried it. Yeah. Say whatever want
here. All seven of them. And, and,
and one of them appears,
and I'm not even sure if
this was one of these seven,
but fuck the draft was upheld as of
in a very important free speech case.
It that by the United
States Supreme Court.
And it is a case that has
ramifications for hate speech as well.
But I cannot describe the facts
of that case on radio or TV.
And you know,
that's laughable in other countries
and we still have anti obscenity.
Well, I mean, let's not forget
that the Brouhaha about the,
the wardrobe malfunction
at Superbowl, I mean, it's,
so we're much more puritanical,
but when it comes to political expression,
there's no country that gives
as much protection as we do,
including for hateful,
racist speech and misogynistic speech,
including four diff
defamation, you know, uh,
defamatory falsehoods about public
officials and public figures.
And that's why,
uh,
there are so many libel lawsuits that
are brought in the UK against what would
be clearly protected
speech in this country.
But you do believe in our libel laws here.
Uh,
yes, I, you know, I,
I'm sure I would want to
trim them back a little bit,
but on the whole were quite protective.
So if it's a matter of public concern
or public official or public figure,
you get quite a bit of leeway.
You can't be held culpable unless you
have acted intentionally or recklessly.
And I think that's correct. And one of
the things, they're pretty specific. Yeah.
One of the things that Trump
wanted to do as he said,
was to reform the libel laws to make
it easier for a public official to,
to collect damages. And you
know, a lot of people say, oh,
come on to dean Britain and Germany
and France and Canada and Australia.
You know, it's not as if they are to
tell a Tarion authoritarian countries.
But if you read the examples in my book
of the kinds of speech that are being
punished,
even with imprisonment,
even with a criminal fines,
and that's the tip of the iceberg
because for every punishment there is,
there are countless numbers of,
of self censorship incidents.
It would really make your skin crawl.
I give examples,
no matter what your ideology is,
you should find something in there
that you would say, oh my goodness,
I can't believe it. So, you know,
uh, France, a couple of years ago,
criminally convicted,
they had of a gay rights organization for
calling the head of an anti gay rights
organization homophobe that was
considered to be hate speech.
Now, fortunately she
wasn't sentenced to prison,
but she was subject to a very stiff,
fine,
$3,500. Uh, and, and, and then you
think, what are the ripple effects of,
of that?
Yeah. Have you guys
track this case with, uh,
the comedian in the UK who had
the dog? Oh yeah. Salute. Yes.
Then I mean, again, like it's like all
right. He, at first he was making a joke.
There's no, there's no exception
for humor or satire. Uh,
when the new online hate speech laws went
into effect in Germany on January 1st,
uh,
the first person convicted or charged
under it was one of the leaders of a right
wing party. Not
surprisingly, but the very,
and then maybe the first two that
were charged were from that party.
But the very next one was a satirical
magazine that was making fun of their
statements, mocking them,
ridiculing and, and, and,
and these laws by being so subjective,
can't make the fine distinctions between
humorous satire and straightforward
advocacy.
Yeah. So my audience knows I'm not
big on this. The globalist ideas here,
or even the UN I think is
mostly a farce at this point.
But do we need some sort of
Internet bill of rights? I mean,
this is a new phrase that seems to be
popping up over the last year or so that
will uniformly protect people in other
country from beer for their ability to
say things that are uncomfortable online
and be able to tweet things, uh, that,
you know, you can't say in Germany,
but you can say in the United States,
I think we have to do that on
a country by country basis.
And I am pleased that there are
advocates in other countries that really
strongly support freedom of speech,
including for hate speech.
And I keep putting that in air quotes
because it, as I say to that person,
and you're at the University
of New Hampshire, no, there
really is no such thing.
And by the way,
there a lot of what they said to you,
some people would consider
to be hate speech too.
So that's another argument
that you could have made.
Do you realize that's my one regret
is at one point when she said to me,
I said something about losing Holocaust,
uh,
family members from the
hot guys on both sides.
And then later she said they're rolling
in their graves over what I'm saying.
I mean, try to think like
this, if we're really,
if we're really gauging the offense meter.
Yeah,
I assure you there was nothing that I
said in those two hours that was more
wildly offensive than that. But do I want
her jailed because of that? I mean, okay.
Yeah.
So I,
I really was heartened at how much support
there is for the American approach.
We were, were often, uh,
attacked as being American exceptionalists
and it wouldn't bother me if we were
the only ones in the,
in the world that we're defending our
free speech principles as long as that is
the right thing to do. But it's
interesting that other people having seen,
despite the good intentions
of sensorium was elsewhere,
how they are leading to results that
no thinking person should accept and
handing over to these online.
So here we get to this question again,
and I'll put it this way,
Dave,
what's the lesser of two evils
to allow these private, uh,
agglomerations of power,
uh,
Internet companies decide,
pick and choose whose speech
is allowed and who's not,
and enforcing their own concepts of hate
speech or pornography or permissible or
impermissible nudity to pick just
a few examples that they enforce.
Would I rather have them have that
enormous power or would I rather have the
government say,
no,
we're gonna check your power to restrict
other people's free speech rights?
And, and to me, that's a very
difficult issue. So that's the, okay,
so that's exactly where we were
before with the universities.
That's where I would say
ultimately right now are for,
I don't know how many k a Internet
companies we have, let's say Comcast. Um,
I'm spectrum from their role one.
Yeah.
You're thinking of the net neutrality
issue and I'm thinking of the social media
that,
you know,
the Facebooks and the twitters having
these armies of enforcer saying that's
hate speech weren't going to take it down.
Right.
So I guess what I would say is that if
there were certain Internet companies
that were saying,
all right,
well we're not going to allow pornography
on our pipes or we're not going to
allow this type of speaker that was each,
I would still prefer that you as the
consumer would have more choice than,
than the government saying,
we have to enforce all these
things. He's way totally.
But because of the,
because of the Internet,
now I know this is a unique situation
related to free speech. That's a little,
I mean in my ideal world, I'm
completely with you. The question is,
and I'm not an economist,
my husband is,
and he tells me that
it's very complicated.
Have some of them amassed so much power
that we should use antitrust type tools
to prevent them for it because that,
that they are denying us choice through
their market power. Right? So this is,
there's a great conversation
to be had there.
This is where my friends
had Prager university who I
agree with on all sorts of
stuff.
They were suing Google Youtube
over restrictions to their videos,
which I was in for because I don't want
the antitrust stuff to be in because to
me that, that then means you just create
a zillion other problems down the road.
But that's a great place for a free speech
person and an economist and probably,
uh, uh, technology guide all sit down and
work this stuff out without choking each
other.
There was a re to me,
really frightening story in the New York
Times a few weeks ago featuring, uh,
Facebook's deletion center.
That's what it was actually called,
this huge building in Berlin where they
had literally hundreds of people that
are looking at individual posts and
deciding, should this be deleted?
It should it not be deleted.
And it was um, you know,
and the examples,
you,
you realize how inevitably
subjective it is.
Ultimately they took down when
they took down this, this, um,
comment that was posted by the politician,
she was calling certain
Muslim men rapists.
And the question was,
was she referring to the particular Muslim
immigrants who were in fact convicted
rapists? There was a horrible incident
on New Year's Eve a couple of years ago,
in which case one would hope that
would be protected speech cause she's
describing something factual or was she
perhaps insinuating that all Muslim men
are rapists? Which would not
be a generalization that I
would find objectionable,
but, and, but it would be illegal
under German law and the official,
you know, these people, it's their
whole job to make these decisions.
They couldn't agree between themselves.
And so of course,
if you're not sure which way it goes
and you're facing a 50 million euro,
fine. If the German government says it
is hate speech while guess what? Right.
Yeah.
What do you, what do you think right
now is our biggest censorship threat?
Where do you think is is
coming on the horizon?
I am going to be very general because
it's been the same answer I've had
throughout my decades of activism,
which is lack of public understanding
and awareness of what the first amendment
is, what it does, protect, what it does,
not protect what the rationales are.
I truly believe that the
more people understand both
what the principles are and
how we have evolved at
toward those principles,
through historic experience,
that people will be supportive.
So I'm curious,
during the whole NFL kneeling thing,
I've made a couple of videos about it
and obviously we talked about it on the
show, but I basically was saying, look,
this is free speech working. The
president said what? He said,
now, I would certainly prefer that the
president not call people sons of bitches,
right? But he's entitled to free speech.
He didn't try to enact a law to stop him,
so he spoke.
The players could then deal or not Neil.
So they were able to do what they
wanted. The owners could then, you know,
find the players or not. So they got to
do what they wanted. The fans could say,
I'm going to buy jerseys and attend
games or I'm not [inaudible] so everyone
speech, actually everyone
speech and action was protected.
You might have some consequences for it.
But to me it was a great example of the
whole thing working messy but working.
Do you think that is
fair estimation?
Totally agree with that.
And I had quite similar analysis myself
to the disappointment of people who did
not realize that the NFL as a
private entity has its own rights,
including its own free speech rights.
And I thought it was interesting that
some of the owners said they would allow
their players, uh, to express
their, their protests.
He's in that case though,
is Trump getting it as close to where
it could be an issue for the ACL,
you or other similar organizations as he
can without directly calling for a law
because there is some other,
I don't even know what that is,
but there's something else
happening there. When you,
he's calling,
he were threatening if he were
threatening to pass a law.
And he did that in one other context.
I think he threatened that there should
be some f an FCC license should be taken
away from some broadcasts or that
comes much closer to the line and the
principal, Dave, you're exactly right.
He does not give up his free speech
rights by virtue of being a government
official. But if he is speaking
in official capacity, um,
and threatening some adverse consequences
that could be seen as an abridgment of
free speech under which would violate
the first amendment. Exactly. Yeah.
So in the past,
I think the closest supreme court case
we have is where a government commission
wrote a letter that threatened that it
would take some action and even though it
wasn't starting a prosecution or it
wasn't an order to seize the expression,
the court said, you know,
it was a very functional,
practical concept.
It would a reasonable person feel deterred
in pursuing their free speech after
they hear this communication.
And again,
reasonable people can disagree
about what the answer to that is.
But that's the question we should put
in evaluating whether Trump has crossed
the line or not.
So one of the things that I saw when the
NFL released its new standard now for
next season where the players are allowed
to stay in the locker room or not.
And again, everyone's choice will,
will or will not have consequences.
I saw a lot of people that were saying,
well clearly the government involved,
you know,
interfered behind the scenes.
Now I know there's no,
I know you don't suspect you don't have
some sort of insight or knowledge on
something like that.
That's where there would be a problem
though if they were really, you know,
behind the scenes meetings where they
were saying you're going to institute this
new policy and that's it. But beyond that,
but short of having that information,
everything kind of works.
Yeah. Um, there, there's
another analogy I can think of,
which is where the government has
threatened certain businesses that if you
don't adopt a voluntary,
uh,
restriction on speech, then we're going
to pass legislation. So, for example,
the movie rating system or
a sound recording rating
systems that we think these
labels are stigmatizing and therefore
suppressing certain expression.
Uh, I think there's a very strong argument
that the only reason this so called
voluntary system,
uh,
was put in place in both businesses is
because they knew that if they didn't do
it, the government was going to
legislate it. Uh, but even that,
the Supreme Court never held that
that was a illegal censorship.
Yeah.
All right,
well we can't talk free speech for
an hour and not mention the cake.
We got to talk about the gay cake.
Tell me your thoughts on the gay k.
Okay. It's, uh, I, first of all,
I think it involves not expression,
which I would define quite broadly.
And again, let me talk about the, the,
the standard here.
Reasonable people can disagree how the
standard applies to the facts of the case.
Um, so the court has said, and I think
this is correct, that something comes,
some expression comes or
arguable expression comes
within the ambit of the First
Amendment if it is intended to and can
reasonably perceived as conveying a
message,
at least a general message.
So that's the question you
would ask about the cake.
I think there's at least a plausible
argument that the cake is satisfied that
standard. Uh, in addition to expression,
there's the question of religious liberty,
right?
Which I defend very strongly,
even more strongly than the Supreme Court,
which has a quite narrow definition now.
Uh,
but I think people should not be coerced
generally to do something that violates
their deeply held religious
or conscientious beliefs.
That's only one side of the equation
though, because neither free,
no speech nor religious
freedom is absolute.
And in general, uh, the court has
said, and I think this is right,
that government can restrict those
freedoms if it can show that there is a
countervailing interests of
such compelling importance
that can only be advanced
by restricting the
expression or the belief.
Uh, and the countervailing
interest is of course the dignity.
And equality of a, in
this case, gay people,
but in past cases,
it's been African Americans or women
because people have cited who are in
business,
have a cer asserted religious
justifications for not
serving members of racial
minorities or not treating women equally.
And,
but to be clear,
that's not what was happening here because
they could have walked in and bought
any cake off the shelf.
A black person,
interracial couple could have walked
in and bought any cake off the shelf.
This was about the specific,
uh,
act that was going to be paint, you know,
painted or whatever they do on the case.
Right. You know, it's interesting.
I, uh, and there's another,
um, another free speech
principle that's involved here,
which is that government may not compel
somebody to proclaim a certain message
that they don't believe in any more than
it may stop somebody from conveying a
message that they, that
they do believe in. Um,
so I would say I, I'm, I'm very,
I think they're very strong
concerns on both sides.
So I'm very sympathetic because, let
me finish out the other argument. Um,
of course, if you are in independent
artists that is, you know,
only taking assignments on commission,
whether it be to paint a portrait
landscape or to decorate a cake in a very
elaborate way,
that's one thing.
But if you are doing business with the
general public and basically holding
yourself out as what the law
would call a public accommodation,
we're open to all comers,
then you may not discriminate
on certain bases such as race,
religion. And I think even though you
still can, as a matter of federal law,
under State Law, uh, in that
state and, and, and others,
you cannot do that on the
basis of sexual orientation.
And so I think that very strong
countervailing equality principle,
I think should,
should dominate in this analysis.
You actually weren't thrilled
with this decision. Well, I was,
I was in the sense that there were so
many ways that the court could have gone
wrong. So many issues.
They said that it was,
I thought the best thing they could do
was to be very narrow. And I actually,
if I were writing a brief in the case,
that's what I would do too.
Because all of these
principles are so important.
I deeply care about freedom of expression,
including the freedom not to be compelled
to affirm a message that that violates
your beliefs, whether they're religious
or conscientious, doesn't matter.
Um,
but I also deeply believe in equality
in the public sphere and the facts were
murky. So I think, you know,
as I think what happened in past
situations with a race and gender,
I think, you know, once things,
once the immediate
resistance died down to uh,
the 1964 civil rights act,
um,
that it sort of worked its way out
in a way that is maximally respective
respectful of all the competing rights.
So I think it's very good to avoid really
broad brush holdings that might have
unanticipated adverse consequences
for other factual situations.
That's an interesting take because
I saw some people saying, well,
they're just sort of kicking
this down the road now.
But basically you're
saying in a weird way,
that's the way a functional society
works at times. I think, you know,
the court sets them general
goalposts and then as time goes by,
the controversy may die down.
People may figure out how they can live
their own lives in ways that they're not
going to be bothered by, by the government
and not being treated disrespectfully.
One of the things that I
really liked about the um, uh,
opinion in that case and uh,
it's so contrasting to what's happening
in the European countries that I discuss
in my book is that the court talked very
strongly about equality and neutrality
in many different,
sorry,
in many different contexts.
So not only that you should be treated
with equal dignity regardless of who you
are,
but also regardless of what you believe.
So the fact that the court was respectful,
both of the equal dignity of the gay
couple and have the equal dignity of their
religious beliefs and the free
speech rights of the baker.
I really liked that.
I'm,
one of the things that bothers me very
much about what a is often paraded as
diversity on campus is that it
only looks at one dimension.
It looks at demographic diversity
in terms of who you are,
but not in terms of of what you believe.
And in these European countries
that are enforcing hate speech laws,
you see them going both ways
depending on who's in power.
So certain religious beliefs are being
punished and criminalize as hate speech
if they run against what is a dominant
secular orthodoxy in those societies.
Uh,
whereas in other communities,
a certain criticism of religion is treated
as hate speech and criminalized when
it's the religious, uh, belief that
is held by those in dominant power.
I think the main takeaway
here is that freedom is messy,
but we're doing a pretty
decent job of it here. Well,
thanks to those who keep agitating, right?
Eternal vigilance. There you go. Well,
it's been a pleasure chatting
with you and for more on a dean,
check out her new book, hate why we
should resist it with free speech,
not censorship. And we're going
to link to it right down below.
Yeah.